it was a wire to wire win for boston in
game one
here's smart on the spot up good for
three
he is six of ten from three
[Music]
an excellent screen setter knows his
role and plays it well
sets up tatum who gets the jumper to
fall jason tatum
clock inside of 10. tatum
has the defender on his head great fake
and then the following on the baseline
drops it in for a second bucket
just two for five good defense that time
by the celtics
here's tatum another three for boston
that's the third of the first quarter
tatum smart williams ogiley shemiojilay
and
brad wanamaker and that is tatum there's
only points tonight coming at the line
tatum weaves his way into the lane
beautiful hesitation and finish this guy
is just a phenomenal offensive play had
a huge impact on both ends of the floor
in this series
sets a screen for tatum fires a three
hit it come on now there was a time
where that kind of pressure
particularly his first year might have
bothered jason at worst
in his third season in the league he
feels the heat from from kyle
the use of the behind the back dribble
because he was cut off and so let me
just put it behind my back i'm gonna get
quickly and efficiently into my but they
did lose game one last year to boston in
the conference semifinals and ended up
winning the next four i think miami is a
better team than that boston team last
year as
tatum with a beautiful step through and
now has 29 points
thursday night van bleed rejected by
tice tatum looking to push
[Applause]
leaves it for smart wide open look
buries a three
i think how good their bench was
remember against brooklyn in game four
they had a hundred points
as uh smart hits another three
and first third of the postseason here
smart three ball again hits again
marcus smart with three three pointers
here in the fourth
i'm a smart defender but guess what i
can shoot threes too
what an improvement nicely done marcus
here in the fourth quarter of game two
can the celtics extend their lead
marcus smart with four fourth quarter
three-pointers
tatum nice pass
smart launches oh it's good and a foul
marcus smart is owning the three-point
line tonight he's got
five triples in the quarter about marcus
smart and the offense he provided in
game one
game two it's been exactly the same
thing
he is starting in place of gordon
hayward they were down
17 and a half points step in mark is
smart
it's on the way no good off the heel
rebounded though by grant williams
tatum he'll try and get it and the
celtics lead by
six they have now made 14 threes
look right look at that defender bite
jason's like this is easy now
i shed him